planetary scientists and this is Rio are  saying that new studies suggest Uranus  probably smells like rotten eggs this is  a true absolutely true story Wow  so it's true Uranus smells like rotten  eggs yes correct absolutely true story  scientists found hydrogen sulfide at the  top of the planets clouds so they're  almost 100% sure  Uranus smells like rotten eggs now as  many of you may have guessed no one is  having more fun with this story than the  seven-year old news network  welcome back to the seven-year-olds news  network and now some breaking news  scientists have discovered that your  reign is heterogeneous that's right time  to just I say  [Music]  7y open  [Music]  I honestly don't see how we are any  better than that I really see no  difference we're a little less  professional yeah a little less  professional  you